I would like to announce our first panel
and I will wait for the slide behind me
it's a panel that is
entitled of systems and prototypes and
indeed it's a panel that tackles systems
prototypes and complexity the tactics
strategies and goals of the design
process that as you can see are also the
strategy tactics and goal of a nation
state and all of an architectural studio
so once again they're expanded to many
different Realms and we will have to
present our speakers first we will have
my Ling Loco my Ling Loco I had never
met in person before but I always
admired her she's an architectural
scientist a designer an educator and
she's now teaching at Yale and also has
a consulting company a design company in
Ghana but I remember following her when
she was at RPI which is a Polytechnic
Institute akin to MIT that is near New
York that has some of the best design
with waste that all over the United
States and I really love it because she
has devoted her life to the upcycling of
agrow waste and biopolymer materials but
she doesn't only talk about them she
also realizes amazingly beautiful
projects with it and I think it's very
important to remember that design is
also form it's also static so that
Elegance is a form of respect and a form
of communication second we will have
xiaoi ye great friend and wonderful
expert in fashion she's actually one of
the foremost voices in fashion criticism
and in fashion also advocacy in China
and in 2017 she founded a consultancy
that's beautiful beautifully called that
is it's called yay yay I love it that
pushes the sustainability agenda among
fashion designers and producers so just
by doing so she could change the world
considering the shape the size of the
market in China last but not least we're
gonna have Aaron maniam who is exactly
the kind of quintessential Singapore
individual that I was talking about
before he's a civil servant therefore a
rock star and a poet and an intellectual
writes poetry with friends and never
sets his mind at rest for the little
that I've known him and can speak about
the future in a way that nobody else can
so with that in mind I'm gonna call to
the stage and help me welcome my Ling
Loco
Carla
good afternoon everyone it's so nice to
be back on this part of the world I
actually grew up in Kuala Lumpur and not
too far from here
and my family would come here to well
for me I would I only came to ride the
Sentosa cable car
so from the perspective of my eight to
nine year old self Singapore was
definitely a place of a future
um and so I'd like to talk today about
two simple prototypes that speak to
today's theme of Designing for the
future by no means are these sort of
solutions
but rather speak to the recognition of
the Prototype the working power of the
prototype to identify value to transform
and circulate that value in a world of
inherited and increasing complexity
so this is what I call the mother
prototype made out of coconut and I call
it the mother prototype because I'm
still learning from it today and in some
ways it's a simplification of a very
complex Global material economy and it's
sought to sort of connect ambitious
outliers in the startup industry in
Ghana collecting Urban agricultural
waste and emerging bioadhesive companies
in Upstate New York you wouldn't
necessarily put these two groups of
people in the same room but they are
bound by this being outliers is
agricultural Legacy
it was also a way of rethinking the
value framework that we have inherited
today
for everything that we make or build
with we know that that value is
typically extracted from our ecology
usually the land
it's transformed through Labor the
conditions of which can range from
slavery to over being overpaid
that value is accumulated by an owner be
that a private Corporation or the state
it's used by consumers and often
produces infinite quantities of waste
materials that we don't have use for
and we know that the system is Rife with
number of forms of alienated labor which
may come in the form of land for example
that has been used over and over again
from monoculture cropping and nutrients
are not returned in a timely manner
we know that this may come in the form
of Labor that is underpaid or working in
harsh conditions be that on the farm or
the factory
consumers who have no idea of the
impacts of what and who is is affected
by the products they consume and no way
to even participate in mitigating those
impacts and by and large this large
generation of waste that actually xiaowi
is talking about
so as an architect and designer I've
become really interested in trying to
understand and experiment with new forms
of agency when we begin to recognize
that for a long time our business model
as Architects has not necessarily
evolved we've sort of occupied this
position between owner and consumer that
drives this top-down extraction cycle
and to really explore this underbelly on
the bottom half of this graph
and so through the development of the
coconut prototype we really saw it as an
opportunity to strategically place
ourselves at the bottom half of this
framework
um it's also you know sort of a case
study in a much larger problem around
agricultural ways which could be
arguably one of the world's most
underutilized material streams it's
renewable it's generated every year and
it's so intimately tied with our growth
as a species because the more we grow
the more food we produce to eat and so
generates this material stream
often we see the premature down cycling
or incineration of these materials
before they even have a chance to show
what they're capable of
so prototyping here is sort of this
ongoing process of proposing new value
for these materials and then in the 21st
century I think this is incredibly
interdisciplinary process and one that
is rapidly accelerated when Academia and
Industry collaborate
as a designer this value identification
process is also Impala's words and
exercise and respect
understanding what these materials are
made from where they come from and all
of the historical processes that went
into making them
and in doing so we open up a whole sea
of material futures
in this case it generated this Continuum
of strong mechanical materials the kind
of stuff that replaces plywood
to materials that are incredibly low
density and breathable stuff that are
incredibly good at filtering and holding
small particles like moisture in our
humid air or pollutants in our indoor
Airstream the second aspect of this
allows us to escape the technological
bubble and really enter the realm of the
social and I think there's an immense
need for this and we can push the value
of the Prototype once we enter this
realm
in many ways there's a lot of Need for
being able to translate the value that
different stakeholders bring to this
framework whether that's nature whether
that's all forms of invisible labor that
we don't adequately recognize
and also what is the currency of
translating these values from natural
Capital to cultural capital to economic
capital and not necessarily in that
order
and lastly in understanding and
translating this value how can we design
a circulation framework where the
distribution of value is dynamic and it
is fair in other ways how do we use this
system to generate Justice
um to a large extent we need this to
address our growing Equity Gap
and this can largely take place in
communities where these robust social
relationships exist or if not the
Prototype is a way of activating and
accelerating these relationships
so this brings me to the second Pro
group of prototypes made out of fungal
mycelium the vegetative state of fungi
and our goal was to really increase
access and participation to people
outside of a factory or Academia or
research lab
uh and it's really based on this idea
that mycelium mycelial technology can
function under really ambient conditions
really low energy to digest a wide array
of agricultural waste to grow new
materials in less than six days
and so for us we wanted to work with our
industrial Partners who typically
manufacture these materials in
controlled factory settings
and we wanted to scale this up not only
the tools but the basic infrastructure
to engage a wider public
putting the prototype in the hands of
the public was sort of a double-edged
sword we could scale up technological
innovation in terms of growing materials
but it was also a form of seating a form
of radical public education around fungi
we were very interested in prototyping
Technologies for participation could we
make custom toolkit to make special
building materials could we use everyday
objects like buckets from Home Depot to
grow new types of bricks
in the first instance that we tried to
do this this was a working with an urban
farming group in Liverpool called squash
nutrition that grows food across the
city in the yards of schools
and through a series of education and
mycelium manufacturing workshops we
worked with 200 people to grow the
panels inoculate and grow the panels
we decided to do this in the actual
gallery of the Royal Institute of
British Architects North to show that
this type of process could happen right
in on site and so you'll see in the
center of the gallery of the grow
chamber and this was sort of used over
the course of two weeks to grow all the
panels that formed a sort of entrance
tunnel to to the gallery itself
in Ireland France which sits in the
kamark region where a large percentage
of or Francis organic produces grown we
sort of blew open the complexity of
taking just agricultural waste and began
to expand this to food waste and waste
from invasive species that was harvested
using a very simple wall system in a
community kitchen called the kitchen
collaborative in grifoi we developed a
sort of hierarchy of standardized panels
ones that we knew how they would behave
and then more experimental forms formed
from the waste coming out of the kitchen
itself for us the architectural Design
Studio in universities is still a very
precious space to test and evaluate all
of our assumptions logistically
technically and also how to rethink how
one might manage the coordination of all
these tasks when you're working on a
community scale before we take such
things public and so this is it
installed flipped over in a in a beach
Forest known for honey mushrooms in
Arnhem in the Netherlands
so I'd like to end by returning to this
diagram that proposes new roles for the
agency of the designer
prototyping in many senses is a working
fluid from actively Thinking by doing
and here we can not only begin to
identify material futures
but really we're immersing ourselves in
small ways in the future while building
it so thank you and look forward to the
discussion
thank you so much Mylene and I would
like to call on stage and introduce to
Singapore yeah
thank you
thank you Paula and thank you for
inviting me here I'm so happy to be here
and to share some of my thoughts about
redesign fashion systems I don't think I
need to introduce myself I think Paula
introduced me much better than my
company profile and this is the image
I'm going to share because three weeks
ago well I've been traveling around the
world because pandemics and then so
three weeks ago I was in Germany
documentar and then this is a one of the
most photographed work it's by Nest
collector from uh Kenya so it's
installation built with Bill of
secondhand clothes or wasted textile
where people ships to like well not
people well actually more correctly
Global knows like I.E European countries
the North American country ships to uh
the global South like for for trading or
for exchange and then so they used this
material to build installation to remind
people about this phenomena and then and
then it's a very beautiful Park revenues
but it looks like a installation by uh
like a dumping site
and then two weeks ago it was like the
whole world of uh the fashion we resumed
so this I think was in New York is one
of the show Zimmerman's I wasn't there
so what's the linkage between these two
images and then do they have any
linkages because when we YouTube when we
talk about Fashions and this is what
comes doing on my mind what is the color
of the Season what is the item we should
be buying what should I wear this with
that and then what is the must-have back
and then so it's all about consumption
of course you talk about designers or
something but in the industry more and
more people will focus and talking about
something like this and then I think I
don't know if you're shocking as me when
I first saw images and story like this
so these are two images talking from or
foundations work it's a foundation they
are uh as a they're more set up in Ghana
so this is the in one of gun is Market
which is eligible state is the world's
largest second-hand trading Hub so every
month I think there's a 25 million
pounds of clothes again be shipping by
global knows to there and then to be and
then there's a three Thirty thousands of
people working on resorting and cleaning
them reprinting them and trying to sell
them again so on the lab you'll see this
young girl it's called Kaya so their
work is their headquarters they need to
carry all these calls through and then
the each
tongues what the the clothes they are
carrying is about on average it's like
55 kilos so I think usually way more
than two so you can imagine the harm to
do with the neck and the spine and a lot
of them like have very serious physical
problems because this is kind of the
work they are doing but even they're
working so hard and then all these
people wins off so still like only less
than 60 percent were close which is
really have certain kind of value
especially increasing with the whole the
rampant fast fashion the more and more
clothes which is actually is valueless
racks end up there so more than 40 will
be sending to the landfill dump site
which on the right hand side you can see
is have seriously polluting the local
like water systems with uh shedding of a
microplastic or like hazardous chemicals
so they must have something wrong from
what we're thinking the beautiful
clothes on the wrong way to like a
polluting Seaside in Africa or like a
severely damaged young girls bodies so
and then oh there's some numbers there
over 100 billions of government are
produced every years and less than one
percent is only being recycled because
of a design problem but actually it's
also a system problem so what is this
system this system usually is we call
linear economy it's simply we take
something we make something and we just
dump it and then without yeah because we
think the resource is cheap and then
infinitive and then we just don't build
them more and more and more so the whole
system like a fashion industry require a
new redesign you need a system change
and then it needs a circular economy
saved by element fossil foundations
because the advocacy on circular
economies so what is circular economy I
think most people probably know but then
I'll just kind of explain a little bit
with this kind of famous butter
photographer so there's like a two size
on the left side the green side is
called biological Cycles so everything
which is kind of biodegradable say like
a full wears or something which uh after
consumer using it can still go through
like they still have kind of Astral
values they can go back cascading in
different kind of value strings and
whenever it's not can be used anymore
they can go through like a bio Refinery
become biochemicals or you can go
through composting compile gas and begin
again it becomes a nutrients to feed
back into the whole soil and system and
on the right hand side it's called
technical cycle is it for things which
cannot be biodegradable say your mobile
phone or your car or Metals so which you
can buy maintenance which is like um so
there actually shouldn't be a consumer
items they can be they should be used
and taken care of and to prolong that
usage due to maintenance to repair it
and then if you don't want it anymore
you can resell every distributed and it
really can not be used anymore and part
of it can be recycled back to the whole
system so circular economy is actually
meant to keep like materials and
products in the loop and then to be uh
trying to be used and reused as much as
possible so it's creating a company
there's no waste and then everything can
return its most values
so and then well there's three
principles about like a circular economy
a limited waste and pollution keep
products and material use and
regenerative natural system but I'm
going to uh trying to attack like
redesigning fashion system from three
different perspectives so first person
is a redesign supply chain so
Bill McGrady was the former Chief supply
chain uh supply chain officer from PVH
previously this large Fashion Group who
owned like Calvin Klein company Hill
figures and and all those companies so
it was saying the first step to change
the system is to stop thinking of Supply
as a chin is actually a match of lattice
which is directly adjustable and
responding across offshore neutral and
onshore collaborative Supply platforms
so the old way we call supply chain is
actually one way it's actually kind of
designed with a retail model it's about
10 20 years old where you produce and
then with of course it's a kind of the
end product of the collaboration so
we're like a western brand with the
branding power with cultural heter money
with the requisition power they become
this kind of conglomatic and then the
design the marketing or whatever and
then you send all the designing order to
the developing countries like mostly in
these regions so because much cheaper
labors and then a huge quality you can
kind of just decrease the the price and
then making more profit and you push it
to the consumers and without their
wanting it or not and you don't want to
you end up with a lot of desktop a
return or damages and all the lowest
values which is not being really con
accounting back to the whole kind of
profit systems so so so so we can
obviously like there's something wrong
about this thing because a lot of value
of laborers energies and materials we're
into it but without being used and not
being being counted for so that's why
like so with this new like
um well first of all I think the biggest
challenge is like so
so this is kind of actually a nowaday
supply chain should looks like so it's
not like a one-way chain it's actually
multiple chin and I.E because like a
more and more consumer demand and
consumer are from not only just develop
develop country but developing country
there's more more markets there's more
consumer demand and with events of uh
digital technology so there's a more uh
you require more agile response and and
also because the interruption of the
supply chain during pandemic so make
people reflect they need to have well
combined official production with Neosho
and then on show so neutral on show is
the imagine the future should be a
hubbed of many like a green and fast
responding Manufacturing in all
different continents plus locally on
show uh providing services and and
repairing and back to the whole Loop so
of course like a redesigning supply
chain also including like human aspect
and natural aspect and human aspect is a
kind of more like working with people
and for the people so this is example
about coal making for Change and the
public schools they work with local
companies uh disinfranchised women and
other than skills so they can also do
like a community manufacturing working
with customers so it both benefit them
also benefit the community and something
else working with natural system which
I'm not going to elaborate because I'm
running over time and this is basically
what melings works were and we just
corresponding each other so second is
redesign material sourcing and based in
another big focus is on biodiversity so
we should we should restore the whole
natural system to make it much more like
to keep the health of the soil and then
the water systems and biodiversity which
you can sequest in more carbons and and
again so like for example like fiber
share they're building this new fiber
system which is both building the
healthy ecosystem and Health Community
and bring those two together and then
eventually bring consumer more close to
the lab and last but not least I'm I'm
going quickly finish it's very important
to redesign experience basically we
design business model so can we come up
with a space model which is based on the
growth and I think yes we can because
more and more designers are thinking
like that for example Crystal Raven will
say is there anything more cooler more
radical than designing nothing but we
can still sell it and then some people
say there's so many old clothes it's
already beautiful lying there how can we
make it even the challenges how to make
it even more beautiful but not doing
something new or can we go through
repair making customers has more
emotional connection with the product
you have and all this is all the values
which can be translated to monetary
value in a way like we can still making
money but without making more new
products so here are four very simple
like uh form one is building your
digital wardrobes and the other swapping
and then and then customizing
um
and the repairing and to make anything
last longer and and of course
re-commerce okay thank you um running
our time and quickly finished my point
thank you
thank you great and I would like to call
to the stage Aaron maniam Rockstar
Paula thank you very much that was far
too kind an introduction than I deserve
but thank you very much also to the
design Council for the invite to to join
you today because this is something I
feel very strongly about and I'm really
glad for the opportunity to talk about
this theme I was very affected by a
recent movie that I'm sure a lot of us
saw and I was really thinking about how
the fact is that you know design is
something that affects and is also
affected by all of us doing everything
everywhere all at once and so as I talk
about designing policy now in addition
to the earlier panels uh the earlier
speakers on designing natural natural
systems as well as designing fashion and
Supply chains I hope you'll see that
this really is something that affects
all of us everywhere all at once
I really wanted to start with seven
basic principles that I think affect the
design of policy not just in Singapore
but using lots of Singapore examples
right and I'll tell you the number seven
now so you can keep that in your head as
we count down you know along the the
list
but I want to start with the place that
all policy has a place of belonging and
this is one of my favorite diagrams it's
called the knife in diagram it talks
about this Welsh word kennethine which
is really the fact that there are
multiple places of belonging and all
policy belongs in one of these four
domains right the known domain which is
the realm of Simplicity where one plus
one equals two and we know with
predictability what outcomes will look
like the complicated domain is a domain
of slightly more involved work where you
might need to do some research but
fundamentally there are still
predictable and stable patterns to be
observed complexity which is the top
left is the world of unclear cause and
effect patterns which is actually where
most policy these days takes place right
unless you're dealing with very fairly
simple things like technical design
and what we're dealing with in
complexity is situations where cause and
effect are not clear and therefore we
have to find ways to tease out those
causes and effects and make sure that we
understand them right whether this is
the world of dealing with online
falsehoods or dealing with demographic
change this is the world where many of
us end up designing either rules and
regulations or norms and policies and
then there's a world of chaos right the
world where cause and effect are utterly
unclear and you can't even discern them
at all
many of us tend to think of policy
including some policy makers that most
of our work lies on the right-hand side
of this diagram but that's not true a
lot of the most interesting work in
policy actually happens on the left hand
side the unordered space so to speak and
knowing that there are these different
places of belonging I think is one of
the first and most fundamental
principles in knowing what sorts of
design principles we we need to apply
this then brings us to a second point
and this is something that Paula and
Dawn both actually started hinting at
already right that all policy is not
just about the present but about the
future as well and you will find that in
Singapore
so much of our policy is acutely aware
about the future it is acutely aware of
vulnerability and we are always thinking
about how we can stay relevant and
anticipate different possibilities
different scenarios in the long-term
future
this is a map really of all the logos of
agencies in government because agencies
are part of the theme today right
agencies that have some kind of Futures
of foresight function this is a list
that has grown phenomenally over the
last 20 years this is a function that
actually began in the ministry of
Defense we experimented it in the
ministry or in what we call the prime
minister's office at the center of
government and that continues to exist
which is why the center there is that
first middle diagram is actually what we
call the center for strategic Futures
which is a quiet little Black Swan in
the middle of the logo I don't know if
you've noticed that
um a bit of design there also that we
kind of mucked around with for a while
but now that this ecosystem has grown
right to include so many other parts of
the government and that's intentional
because we do believe that all policy is
about bringing into bear the relevance
of the future third and this actually
will directly
um
Echo what xiaoi just talked about all
policy is what designing experiences I
have a slightly rebellious streak in me
and I often say to all my colleagues who
are willing to listen that everything we
do in policy is designed because we're
either designing something for the
public to experience or businesses or
we're designing something for our bosses
right and if you write an email thinking
it's going to be read on a laptop but
you forget that your boss actually
checks their email on their phone then
you have designed for the wrong
experience right the experience has to
take care of the human needs that this
individual might have and these are just
some examples of how we've tried to
apply experience design in our work the
left hand diagram is the ministry of
Manpower where they realized that when
people come and collect work passes they
often have real problems finding child
care and so one simple way to make the
the design of the experience more
pleasant and palatable is to have space
for children to actually hang out and
that made the process of collecting
passes for you know foreign workers so
much more pleasant and it made even more
unpleasant outcomes much more palatable
for people the bid on the right that
diagram is really that letter really is
all about how we've used social norming
and again the designing of experiences
in the letters that people receive so
that there's a bit of subtle nudging and
behavioral movement to having people pay
things like their taxes or do their
contributions to the central Providence
Fund in as punctual a way as as possible
right and so we experimented with things
like printing on different colored paper
social norming and telling people what
else their colleagues were doing and we
found that they were actually
interesting results along those lines
the reason these first three principles
are so important right complexity
Futures and experience design is really
because everything we do in policy
explores interdependencies this is one
of my favorite quotes right from the
quantum physicist David Baum and I think
everything we do actually is about
policy making in a world that has
potential for quantum entanglement
everything is interconnected because the
universe is unfolded in everything and
each thing is unfolded in the whole as
we do our policy design therefore we
have to find ways for the whole to
nourish the part but also for the parts
to add to and complement and contribute
to that whole and this sense of
interdependencies is why we often speak
about whole of government policy making
or whole of nation policy making because
none of us can do this alone and we need
to bring the interconnectedness to bear
as much as possible in policy work
number five is really the idea that the
data that we use in policy needs to be
far more diverse and variegated than it
has been before we're very Adept in most
governments at using quantitative data
we're much less Adept at understanding
the importance of narratives and stories
and ethnographic data as someone who
works a lot with qualitative data myself
both in in my personal research as well
as the work that I do I think this is
something we need to address quite
quickly especially because in the world
of complexity in in order to deal with
unclear causes and effects we have to
find ways to tease out the stories right
ask people what makes them happiest or
most irritated about policies that are
out there and programs and events that
they've been part of and when we get
those open-ended questions out there I
think we find really interesting data
points that can allow us to act in a
much more concrete way this is why
Clifford Gates's work on ethnographic
approaches right this fundamental
anthropological approach to policy
making I think is a critical thing we
need to do and it's an important balance
right which is why the work of the
design Council and why festivals like
this are so important because building
out our qualitative literacy is
something that we need to have both as a
policy making outfit as well as policy
consumers like all of you I wanted to
talk a little bit about experiments as
well because you've heard about
prototypes from both mailing and xiaoi
and prototypes can only happen if there
is an experimental culture and mindset
if we are willing to try even if we
don't know what the outcomes are if we
know what the outcomes are then we're
actually just templating right that is
not an experiment experiments have to be
about not knowing and being willing to
put resources into potential failure and
of course we have to calibrate those
resources we don't want to roll things
out at a nationwide level
if we're not sure about the results but
we can run prototypes beta tests small
scale experiments this is one of my
favorite examples where nine years ago
we ran an experiment to offer free rides
on the mass rapid transit system for
people who took the train before 7 45 am
now I know many of you are probably
wondering why would anybody ever do that
but some people did right but what we
realized was not enough people did it
for us to then justify this being a
policy going into the future but I love
the fact that we tried we experimented
with it for months we looked at what the
data told us and then we responded to
the feedback of that data in figuring
out whether we wanted to roll things out
as a more detailed policy or not and far
more of our policies I think need to run
on experimental data of this kind
finally let me say a little bit about
policy involving participation and play
this is where the other agency becomes
important right not just the government
agency but the agency within each of us
we need to participate a lot more in the
design process and that's why you'll
find that many processors in Singapore
these days are all about how we can do
policy work together government has huge
responsibilities and must undertake
those but we can involve citizens to
help counter and complement our
cognitive biases as well as the Deep set
assumptions we might be bringing to the
world and if in that process like the
Singapore conversation which is a the
the process that produced the chart that
you see on the left in that process we
need to try and include more play
related elements as well I think we are
far too often too serious about the work
that we do and we need to bring elements
of serious play into that world this is
why at our civil service College we
actually set up a simulation training
laboratory that looks at designing
serious games for both training purposes
as well as for policy design so that as
we immerse people in potential play-like
situations we gain data and we get a far
deeper insight into the process that
they go through in understanding
policies so there you go seven
principles to understand everything
everywhere and everyone's role in the
policy process and I hope these are
themes that we can come back to as we go
through the Q a uh very shortly thanks
very much
wonderful job
you can stay and I'm actually gonna call
back on stage shall we in my link would
you mind coming over thank you this was
quite an amazing panel what is great is
that you don't often see fashion and
architecture of agrawaste and policy
together but there were many points of
connection which I really love so
your three designers you know and you
deal with systems so let's talk about
one of the biggest cliches of design you
know the cute chair cliche that always
drives me crazy let's talk about
Elegance formal elegance and its power
right its power to convince and its
power to just like convey the message
first of all we all want to know who
designed the Black Swan of the whatever
it's called Center Center for strategic
Futures yeah that is amazing yeah his
name is Bernard toe actually he's
working on a few sets of different
policy regulations now in the digital
space but yeah he was it was his first
job and he did a wonderful task with it
I think yeah and me really good so
um
once I was running this conference with
scientists and designers together and
they were asking each other's question
and the designers were asking the
scientists why is it that whenever you
show a PowerPoint you use the worst
background and ugliest typeface and you
and you really make it ugly otherwise
what's your problem oh we're afraid that
we won't be taken seriously if we make
things too pretty so let's talk about
that in your role as a policy maker and
civil servant how do you use
formal Elegance
and does your work as poet influence
that
wow Paulo that's a big set of questions
uh there but I love that you you began
with that because I do think like I said
earlier everything we do is actually
policy design
um and then I said to to my team before
you know sometimes the formal Elegance
applies in terms of the overall
experience that we're trying to create
this might be about you know the quality
of the the material that you see let me
give you a very concrete example of this
right we had a set of scenarios some
years ago where we wanted to think about
potential for you know Regional
destabilization how we were going to
deal with the US and China and its
increasing rivalry in the world and we
could have just written that up right in
kind of traditional government report
like 100 Pages lots of footnotes very
very rigorous and we had a version that
was that of course because rigor should
not be compromised but we figured that
the best way to actually communicate
this was not in these enormous reports
which highly pressurized decision makers
are not going to have time to read what
we did instead was we produced three
articles uh it's kind of simulating
products that they would normally see so
we had one kind of mock Economist
article we had one article that was from
the South China Morning Post simulated
of course and then we simulated another
one of what we call the Daily Press
clippings right these go on online every
day to a major group of decision makers
and it's just a summary of what's out
there in in the press and we decided
that we just simulate the cover page of
that right and so when you send things
to people that are Vaguely Familiar but
also then have minor iterations because
suddenly they realize oh I'm reading
this product and it's meant to be the
Daily Press clippings from 2027 right or
it's going to be the economist online or
the economy so that was the little pun
that we made right e Dash Economist
because it was all happening in the
digital space in the year 2027. you then
give yourself license to Riff on the
present and I think that's an example of
where you can play with formality but
take it in in directions that allow for
people to question the Deep assumptions
that they might have this is just one
example of how with communicated Futures
thinking and I always think of that as a
way of dealing with creating experiences
for people that they can both relate to
but use as a base from which they
question themselves as well thank you
shall we your same question but from
another angle because you live in a
world where a static form is one of the
Primal drivers right so how do you
how do you reconcile the need for
sustainable approaches with Aesthetics
or do they need to be reconciled at all
I mean there was a moment in which being
sustainable meant wearing bad sandals
and you know and and just like bad
messenger bags and now instead it's
definitely not like that but so do you
ever have any issues combining the two
or not anymore well I I think not
anymore for various reasons number one I
think of course if you're talking about
fashion or design everything I mean it
should be beautiful but depends on your
definition about building three why but
I think more or less everyone is kind of
the same so and then I think it's like
when it wasn't so beautiful because
there was a limited practice because
because there's only certain sector of
people who are like sustainable
designers well whatever and also
available materials not so many the
projects is not so many and consumer
doesn't understand about that so there's
certain kind of image but not actually
sustainability is in the mind of every
designers I mean the young designer
they're well educated they will think
about that by themselves so so so it's
still you need to design something which
is desirable because I mean fashion
industry is still somehow is selling on
desire but as to what is desirable which
is important because like can we I think
one of the designers who's saying
something very interesting which is
totally I think like can we desire can
we design like not just only Beauty and
Identity or whatever design social
belief and social value into the new
identities because people love fashion
because it's something to show who you
are whatever right so I want to be
belong to this tribe and I imagine I'm a
Renaissance princesses whatever but then
but then what about all this social
belief what about your commitment it
should be part of a value and it should
be designed within your design languages
I like the fact also that you said that
some of the young designers just have it
in them so it's a new Baseline it's not
anymore something that has to be a
design behavior that you need to teach
but right now it's part of the process
so you don't need to abdicate Beauty in
order to show uh I know in order to show
piety you know so interesting and my
link in your case you um you teach aggro
waste use and an approach whereby you
use what you have to make what you want
in different parts of the world so still
still sticking to form into Elegance
material culture of different places and
the use of aggro waste can you say
something about that please
yeah I mean I think maybe uh was it
Ghana where you did the workshop or was
it was it round I can't remember that
was uh my son was in Liverpool no but
there was another Ghana in Ghana yeah so
much like Singapore Ghana is very much
concerned with building
and extuing this sort of modern identity
so when we're designing aggro waste
building materials we're going up
against identities of materials like
concrete and glass and steel which are
you know materials of of the future they
communicate wealth and all sorts of
things
and so the the pressure to give these
low value materials limitation marks a
new identity is much higher
um because you have to change the social
perception
um and so we kind of fall back to some
of the more basic Humane uh Human
Relationships that we have with material
how do you
seduce produce desire desire to touch
materials for example so a lot of the
tactility although there's a
environmental performance is about
getting people to you know touch the
nooks and crannies of some of these
materials
um and it's also about trying to also
celebrate the impermanence of some of
these materials and it's a tough one you
know I think a lot about how we have
examples in our lives of things that
when they age they increase in value
maybe it's a blanket that as it goes
over time it gets softer and just the
right amount of comfort or leather you
know you stretch into it and whatnot
um and so that that aesthetic is is
quite difficult to design and capture we
do that with my student primarily
through through texture it gets this
velvety sort of surface if you on the
sixth day it's a long story it just gets
velvety but but those type of qualities
are some of the things that we try to
use to to build a connection between you
know people and these materials
and in doing so hopefully cast a new
identity for them
um so yeah it's it's a challenge but I
think
it's probably the most difficult
audience to design for the Hunger to
appear modern
and then the materials that you have
right at your feet that you don't
necessarily value
or material and identity it's really
deep I don't know so the most voted
question from the audience is for you
and it's it's how can the public service
be more open to prototyping and
experimentation when there are
constraints in time and resource they
don't know that that's much faster than
the other way you tell us money the
constraints in time and resource are
exactly what helps us to prototype
better I mean that CSF logo was not the
result of you know us paying a
consultant millions of dollars right
Burnett designed it on PowerPoint
um and then we kind of prototyped it a
little bit more and we thought okay this
is great let's go with it
um no but I I think there's a fair
question at heart it goes back to the
what is that diagram I started with you
know the kidnapping diagram
the the world of constraints and and
resource optimization is particularly
important in on the right side of that
diagram right what you would call the
audit space where there are predictable
outcomes and we need to realize that in
those instances we want to achieve
technical efficiency but in the world of
complexity where we want to run
experiments it's not that we want to be
profligate with the resources right
we're not saying run experiments in a
way that is utterly wasteful we want to
run experiments that are calibrated with
clear questions that are being asked but
they must be questions there must be
things where we have we don't know what
the answer is where we have hypotheses
that can either be falsified or not and
that's why we run the experiment and I
think a lot of this actually boils down
to two things one is it's about
individuals being willing to say we're
going to start this and it might fail
but if we fail here are the things we
are willing to learn right to set up a
sense of what the lessons are going to
be and what the insights will be and
then it's about leadership also setting
in place a culture whereby they
encourage that sort of
open-ended questioning and to say all
right I'll let you do this but we do it
for three months we run the experiment
and then we look at the data rigorously
so we don't waste Resources by running
it indefinitely but we actually allow
the experiment to give us the insights
and give us data and feedback about what
the universe is actually up to that I
think allows us to both balance right
between the needs of constraints and
optimization but at the same time allow
us to ask these open-ended questions and
move to get answers to them
thank you that's great first away
do you think that a fully circular
system in fashion or any other industry
where design and production is involved
is actually possible
yeah I think it's possible but I don't
really think it's going to solve my
problem it's not going to solve all the
problems we have right now because I
think now the whole fashion industry
depends on circular economy as if if we
reach a circular economy it would be
fine so we can still keep producing more
and more because all the nutrients will
go being going back into sorry we cannot
pour the water for you because of
coveted regulations okay for yourself
not
[Laughter]
so circular is not the only answer you
know there was another question I'm
gonna mix it in with this it was
somebody was asking us about D growth
but because I think it's you
fundamentally you need to change the
business model because now a lot of
people rely on circular as a way like
things we can endlessly which is
question mark circular everything so we
can keep producing we keep in keep
buying more we can keep disposing it so
but I think the problem is this kind of
keep producing more keep buying more
keep selling more because we still need
to going after the growth that's the
fundamental thing so that's why the I
think more more people really good
thinking is can we have a d growth
economy can we still have a Prosperity
but without going after this kind of
infinite growth and that's why like more
Progressive designers of brands are
trying to do and that's it last night I
was discussing with Jacqueline pillow
and why does everything always have to
get bigger yes you know it's like why
okay so this Symposium is based on the
idea of really preaching system thinking
and we're we've been talking about our
own systems but I would like to ask you
do your different systems talk to each
other ever and how
oh yeah
um yeah so clearly not right well I mean
totally they should so let's talk about
it I mean definitely I mean shall we
showed the photo of the or Foundation
doing work oh yeah
actually my link is also working with
them yeah okay
but you know
um
I've worked a lot with textile companies
sort of small home-based Enterprises
and so they're they're women who work at
home so
completely distributed
um and they die and some of them have
got very smart and have come together to
die together and the result is that we
concentrate the toxic water effluent
coming out of the batiking process
and so one of the things that we've been
working on is developing from this new
superfood called Moringa I don't know if
that's famous here
not yet not in the United States maybe
here Miranda okay but there's a waste
product that is amazing at treating the
textile Wastewater effluent it helps all
the bad stuff heavy metals clamp
together and settle
and
um essentially you get clean water which
is below EPA regulations but then you
also get the sludge
another byproduct what do you do with
that and we discovered we could make
these really interesting sludge bricks
um but then when you put it into
practice you realize you have this
infinite resource of sludge bricks that
are quite toxic
and and we just realized we're just
treating the symptoms of a terrible
system from the start and so we've kind
of gone back to work with natural dyes
um
and it's two of them that I I came to
meet the or Foundation
um uh they're essentially working on
thinking about textile circular economy
as part of a public health
infrastructure and I think that's really
important that we see this type of
material framework is very much about
the health of our ecosystem
and digitally I mean honestly I mean
waste is something that is everywhere
and it's also low quality so in terms of
dynamic distributed
variables it's it's a really difficult
system to model
um so you know we're sort of working
with industrial Engineers trying to
model how to predict supply and demand
and then once you even get that under
control how do you organize people on a
certain scale to change or transform
these materials which is a logistical
digital infrastructure really that is
behind it so yeah it's a it's a physical
and digital exercise
um so yeah definitely I think we also
discussed about this like in terms of
fashion when we talk about like making a
much better supply chain well I think
the whole digitalization is quite
important but the thing is it kind of
usually just only tackle one power upon
so you make more agile response you
produce well then you produce maybe more
on demand but that doesn't mean you
produce less it produce even faster and
you're selling in for much cheaper money
and Advantage but because you cut down
so many ways and Coast so it's it's it
looks more kind of more efficiency but
in a way it makes the whole fast fashion
become super fast fashion exactly and
then that's actually a very terrible
visual Circle because some other
components need to come in to this kind
of equation not just all about
efficiency and does anybody ever talk to
Aaron and tell him you know because
these are wicked issues I mean it's like
you make things so fast
and the thing necessarily available yes
no exactly and I think what you're
describing here right is this idea that
we do need to get all of a system into
the room right all the systems within a
larger system into the room having these
conversations with one another and
that's partly why these the
participatory processes that I mentioned
in my last slide are so critical right
because it's about bringing these
different sets of assumptions these
different World Views different ways of
seeing into the a discussion with one
another so that hopefully there can be
mutual learning
um and then sometimes actually have the
systems potentially even conflict but
find ways for the the space of that
conflict to actually be resolved along
the way I think this is a different kind
of role for government compared to what
we might normally be very very familiar
with right we're familiar with
government as provider of security the
government is a taxation Authority we're
familiar with governments as imposers of
order all those are important jobs and
functions but increasingly in complex
spaces governments have roles as
conveners as facilitators and
aggregators as well this doesn't mean
they abdicate their responsibility and
say all right well you people just
decide right talk to one another talk to
me and then we'll make a decision
together sometimes governments have a
role to play in making decisions but I
think that creation of the space that
convening function is actually quite
critical and that allows for the voices
that both mailing and shall we have been
talking about to actually emerge and be
part of the conversation and actually
one other question from the audience is
what is what happens I mean citizens and
governments can think about all these
things but very often it's businesses
that innovate and that build the future
and then sometimes we have to catch up
with them by regulating them turning
that down how do you deal with that
you know there's this great uh F Scott
Fitzgerald a novel that I'm very short
story that I'm very fond of it's called
the crack up and and he writes in it
that the test of a first-rate
intelligence is the ability to hold two
opposing thoughts in the mind and
continue to function the key being of
course continuing to function right not
just having the two thoughts and then
falling apart uh in in the whole process
I hear some ruthful recognizing laughter
here we've clearly all been in these
sorts of situations
um and the key I think to answer your
question right is to find ways to to
balance those polarities right to to be
part of the the participation to be part
of of engendering the conversations but
at the same time in certain instances
recognizing that we don't consult on
everything no government worth their
soul is going to ask people how much tax
would you like to pay right because no
matter how lovingly that question is us
the answer is not going to be one that
optimizes the macro economy but you can
ask people how do we design better
experiences for you how do what can we
do on the land Transport Systems to make
sure that those experiences are designed
in the best possible way we can design
education better this is not about
consultation in the extreme it's about
consultation to do better policy and
better delivery so I think we need to
hold those those tensions those
trade-offs are in our heads a lot more
and then continue to function
um talking about the design of
experiences that was really
uh I don't want to say well that's that
was another question that I won't have
time to answer to ask you all should we
do away with the word consumer
consumption Etc but um
experience has become really fundamental
also both for people who want to sell as
much as possible and also for people who
want to educate as much as possible so
can you tell about the educating side of
the experience designing fashion
education well I think one thing is like
what maling just mentioned like because
like when an object looks older it
appears to have more value but
unfortunately that's not the fashion
reality everything that people want the
next new things yeah so I think there's
this culture so how do you design
certain countries if you make people
appreciate it something actually has
experienced somebody has so one of my
favorite subject right now is repairing
yeah because I think that's kind of the
the most underrated like in all this
talk about how do you upcycle something
how do you use desktop or how this
common practice in sustainable fashion I
think that's one of the most underused
ones called repairing because when you
want to repair something you already
have an emotional attachment to that
stuff and also because
um the reason I'm thinking here because
I use Mentor young designers and he is
the only he is a Japanese designer
living in Vienna his only designer I
thought he do study about this roughly
about 100 120 where about the Japanese
way of repairing textiles and the
patterns the skill the needle works it
looks so beautiful it looks more
beautiful than some of the Couture
coasters like Series in India so how
come no one is kind of really promoting
that so and then so it's not only
preserved the traditions and preserve
the objects and then it can add so much
more economic value to that piece of the
work and then so I mean that's just one
of the ismos I'm constantly looking into
people repairing things great great
answers I feel like I feel like when you
have to repair something you learn more
about it yeah from our bodies completely
true objects aesthetic value that looks
so much more beautiful with all those
stitches and whatever adding on to it
very true too fast questions to end life
cycle of your lifespan of your materials
was that from the audience yeah yeah I
always get that
um yeah of course what you do it's like
I would treat any of these materials
like wood you know if you take care of
it you don't expose it to continuous
moisture you know you allow it to dry
you allow it to breathe they'll last a
long time
the mycelium in outdoor conditions yeah
it rains a ton obviously it's going to
degrade
um because it just houses other
organisms that begin to degrade it but
there's a lot you can do to improve its
its lifespan and I think we're barely
scratching the surface yeah exactly we
need to see what happens right it's one
strain out of five million and we only
know that's eight percent of all the
fungi so Aaron biggest failed experiment
the whole point about experiment is that
they shouldn't be big
um
bilingualism is one of those policies
that we set up with predicated on the
assumption that everybody could be that
most people could be equally good at two
languages at the same time
um I think we realized along the way and
Minister Mentor Lee kuanu did say this
himself that that was probably an
assumption that was flawed some people
can and we want those people to build
that bilingualism as well as they can
but the fact that we introduce
gradations of language training in
primary and secondary school I think
tells us that some of the initial sets
of assumptions needed to be updated
thank you great job
[Applause]